there's been talk about it all week now
the full GOP memo alleging bias in the
investigation of the Trump campaign is
out and there is a lot to unpack so
let's bring in chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge to
break it down for us Catherine
well thanks Dana this newly declassified
four page memo first reported by Fox
News makes the case that the secret
national security court was kept in the
dark by the FBI and Justice Department
when they sought and secured a
surveillance warrant for Trump campaign
aide Carter page the memo says the court
was never told the former British spy
who was paid by Democrats to put
together the Trump dossier
that's Christopher Steele had a personal
animus towards the presidential nominee
quote in September 2016 Christopher
Steele admitted to Justice Department
official Bruce or his feelings against
then-candidate Trump when Steele said he
quote was desperate that Donald Trump
not collected and was passionate about
him not being president
or was recently demoted over his
contacts with Steele in Glenn Simpson
whose opposition research firm Fuzion
GPS directed the Trump project bank
records obtained by the same House
Committee show ORS wife Nellie worked
for fusion GPS and began investigating
Trump as early as May 2016 Republican
investigators said the court was also
never told about the dossiers political
roots quote none of the initial FISA
application in October 2016 nor any of
the renewals disclosed or referenced the
role of the DNC Clinton campaign or any
party campaign in funding Steele's
efforts even though the political
origins of the steeled dossier were then
known to senior DOJ and FBI officials
according to the memo deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe who was removed
earlier this week testified before the
committee in December of last year that
they would never have gone for a
surveillance warrant if hadn't had not
been for the dossier one question so
speaker Ryan and the White House both
said today that they would be they had
encouraged the Democrats to try to
release their version of the memo do you
have any idea of what the timing of that
might be well they've got to go through
a number of processes in terms of
classification I think one of the big
distinctions with the Republican staff
memo is that it was deliberately drafted
with the idea that it could be made
public quickly so they eliminated a lot
of national security information sources
methods anything that was sensitive
the Democrats version is 10 pages long
but it would also be subject to an
interagency review so it could take some
days all right Thank You Katherine
preciate it welcome president Trump
shared his thoughts on the memo from the
Oval Office today moments before it was
released I think it's terrible you want
another truth I think it's a disgrace
what's going on in this country I think
it's a disgrace that's going on a lot of
people should be ashamed of themselves
and much worse than that
let's see what happens but a lot of
people should be ashamed thank you very
much all right we'll take it around the
table starting with Kimberly who knows a
lot about the FBI process and getting a
FISA warrant and all that goes into it
your thoughts yeah there was a few
things that jumped out to me right away
that are sort of like the exclamation
points and what I thought was
interesting is that they excluded the
political origins on the steel dossier
that were known to senior DOJ and FBI
officials but they were left out and
excluded from the FISA applications and
I feel that that that in and of itself
is sort of glaring because it shows like
so the motive the intention and intend
to deceive some duplicity on their part
which i think is totally inappropriate
in terms of what they were supposed to
be transparent about and put forward and
proffer in terms of supporting
documentation and what they knew and if
they knew about the political origins of
it that in and of itself should have
cast doubt on the credibility they
purposefully withheld that information
so to me that is a significant glaring
factor and probably it's like number one
on my list just about another part of it
was that that the media helps play a
role in this in a way so apparently
steel leaked information about the
dossier to Yahoo News Yahoo new rights
the article and then apparently the FBI
when applying for the warrant says that
there was corroboration because it was
in Yahoo News but they didn't make it
explicit that they had actually used
their own steel used his own information
to get it into the Yahoo news what do
you think of that well I don't think
much of it I mean I said to me it
doesn't matter clearly the FBI cut off
contact with steel once they suspected
that he was leaking information but this
thing is so comical to me I was you know
I just I said to Gregg in the greenroom
Gregg you're a seer because this is 0
this is comical I was thinking there's
going to be
something here's some element here
that's really going to cause people to
take a second look instead you have a
situation where Kimberly was talking
about steel having some political
dislike for President Trump that doesn't
speak to the information in the memo and
secondly guess what it didn't even
prompt the investigation the
investigation had started before with
the news that the FBI had uncovered of
George papadopolis connection with
Russian agents who were trying to win
him over and that is included in the
memo yeah and so I don't understand and
then secondly don't forget that Carter
page had been under FBI scrutiny since
2013 Dana so again this is not even
pertinent I mean I don't get it this you
know I'm struck by the number of
Republicans Republicans who have said
today this I'm thinking of John McCain
who said basically that Nunez and the
Republicans here are doing Putin's work
John Kasich said it was an attack on
American institutions and erodes our
democracy John Thune said we got to get
past this this is not good
I don't get it and so President Trump
says they're ashamed he should be
ashamed of using newness in the Congress
in this way well Jessie I'm assuming you
think differently level one says he
thinks it's comical but you're not
laughing I'm laughing at Juan's thesis
it's a kill shot Juan knows it so he and
the reason why I can't admit it is
because to admit it he would have to
admit that he's been wrong for a year oh
good they were caught red-handed in a
conspiracy that the left accused the
Republicans of being involved in it
involved the media and involved Hillary
operatives in foreign countries it
involved the Department of Justice and
the FBI under Barack Obama you say the
FBI cut off contact was steal after they
caught him leaking many backdoored
through the Justice Department and the
person whose wife was working for us and
GPS ended up being demoted Bruce or you
say this didn't prompt the investigation
you know what did prompt the
investigation struck the Trump hating
corrupt FBI officials so what's worse
you're also saying this me
yeah struck responded when Papadopoulos
was found to being being recruited by
the Russians and then he was
subsequently taken off the investigation
okay so he hates Trump the fix was in he
cooked up the Hillary deal and then
opens up an investigation on
Papadopoulos off of some conversation
over in London that's not a big deal on
to me it is you know what else is one
James Comey is signing off on three
these advisor FISA application warrants
and he knows the application was based
on a document the dossier that was paid
for by Hillary and was unverified in
salacious why would he do that where
he's that first of all it wasn't based
on there's no indication this was the
total basis for it set it under oath no
did you not see the thing that Bret
Baier sent earlier that said that the
Democrats are disputing that that McCabe
didn't say those exact words and so who
knows maybe when their memo comes out
Greg will have more information on that
well you know the thing is I since this
whole thing started this nerd Super Bowl
I said that I didn't think there was any
there was gonna be a big tear so I don't
have a dog in this hunt I'm not
interested in being proven correct that
nothing happened here but I'm very when
somebody says there's nothing to see
here that means there's something to see
here because there's always something
and it's clear when you look at this
that there is something and when you
step back and you see this mosaic of
malfeasance when you see things like the
tarmac and you see things like the
servers in the text messages in the
Comey statement and then you see the
political roots of this dossier and why
the political roots of the dossier were
covered up well why will we do that why
would they do that
it stinks of Clinton this is all about
Hillary Clinton she is she I mean this
is to help her get elected we spent the
last year the last year and a half
hearing about collusion between Donald
Trump and the Russians and all along all
along the real collusion was committed
by the perpetrators of that narrative so
if you look at the media that Democrats
and their allies in government those are
the people that have been colluding
they've been colluding about a narrative
and they were colluding before the
election if you think that's not huge
then you're probably a hack you know in
the conservative echo chamber say bigger
than Watergate that would say to this to
spy on what does it make who pays for it
if the information information from a
guy who's like civil I'm like a kind of
a seedy character I'm not saying is real
I'm just saying that that is bonusing
usually the dossier to get a warrant
it's like trying to buy beer with a
library card the process because I am
curious about this and we don't know
this from the memo that so if Carter
pages under a FISA warrant starting in
2013 and you have to go to the FISA
Court every 90 days in order to keep up
that wine we don't know if there was a
lapse in the warrant between 2013 and
2016 but we and we don't know if this
was a new warrant about Carter page
right yeah so the problem is there's a
whole chronology issue here as well in
terms of when do they get it is this
new at what time and it also goes to the
larger issue as Jesse was saying a
veracity in terms of the integral you
know contents and the facts that are
alleged there so if you have a question
about that you have to verify it to make
sure that it was substantiated there was
some kind of indicia of proof or
evidence to support any of them can I
ask you one other thing very orange is
legal point which is because I'm gonna
give you one more chance to talk since
these guys talk a lot um if you're a
FISA judge and you are you were
presented information that you think was
based on faulty information like how mad
are would you be and what are the
consequences of that kind of 1 through
10 furious yeah furious because you
somebody can be held in contempt of
court lying to the court preferring
false information or false affidavits I
mean this goes to the integrity of the
whole judicial process and saying that
in good faith and belief that you have
the information that you're relying on
is truthful and should be relied on by
an officer of the court in order to
justify essentially a surgery and that's
why I get that idea that here I'm
imagine if you're presenting to the
judge you don't say one of my pieces of
evidence as an article from Yahoo News I
mean that make that that that's actually
what they're saying was one of the one
of the pieces I I don't know all the
details here and we'll find out if the
Democrats are gonna come out with their
memo and we'll have more of a full
picture